over the years marvel has populated its
sprawling cinematic universe with an
extraordinarily talented cast of actors
and actresses
but the studio has still never quite
been able to grab keanu reeves for a
role and that's not for lack of trying
either
so just why hasn't reeves shown up in
the mcu so far
everyone knows marvel likes to lock lead
actors into hefty multi-picture deals
such as chadwick boseman's reported five
film contract and sebastian stan's
whopping nine movie deal and while
signing a marvel movie contract comes
with many many perks there's no denying
that agreeing to film half a dozen
movies over the course of a few years
definitely cuts down on the number of
other projects an actor can take on
other actors like john krasinski and
emily blunt have previously discussed
the projects they wouldn't have been
able to make
if they'd taken a role in the mcu and
it's possible that reeves has had this
on his mind whenever marvel approaches
him about a role
in this case it's likely that reeves
reluctance to join the mcu
is less about what marvel is offering
him and more about the roles and
opportunities he could be forced to give
up one such role could be the third
installment in the villain ted franchise
although bill and ted face the music is
currently filming a third movie in the
beloved 80s franchise has been on
reeve's to-do list for a long time
excellent since at least 2010
reeves has been openly discussing his
hopes of making a bill and ted
three-quarter but the film has taken
years to get off the ground
and even once the movie finally looked
as though it might finally move into
production
the journey hasn't been without its
obstacles particularly in the financing
and creative rights department
with bill and ted 3 on such shaky
grounds reeves may have been reluctant
to make a commitment to marvel
that would have made face to music even
harder to schedule if making this movie
was indeed such a high priority for him
it makes sense that he wouldn't have
wanted to hand over such a large chunk
of his time and energy to marvel before
it was finalized
no one expected the first john wick
movie to spawn such a successful
franchise
least of all keanu reeves when reeves
and chad stahlski were initially
shopping around the script for the first
film
they were given a hard no by pretty much
every studio in hollywood when they
finally did get to make the movie
it was done on a relatively tight budget
of 20 million dollars
many of the artistic choices in john
wick including the long takes and
close-up combat were made due to budget
constraints
as a production couldn't afford multiple
cameras or fancy editing
but despite low expectations john wick
went on to be successful enough
to justify two sequels with another on
the way the bill and ted and matrix
films aside
reeves isn't typically a franchise actor
and the only other movie he's worked on
since the birth of the mcu
that hasn't been a standalone was toy
story 4. of course john wick wasn't
intended to be any different but
considering the runaway success of the
john wick films and reeves ongoing
involvement as a titular assassin reeves
may not want to sign up for another
major film franchise
until he wraps up the franchise he's
already in in fact that's exactly why he
turned down the part of yon rug and
captain marvel because he had to work on
john wick 3.
so the bad guy part went to jude lore
instead and reeves remained
tantalizingly out of reach for the
marvel cinematic universe
in a surprising development that
practically no one saw coming
variety broke the story in august 2019
that
16 years after the matrix revolutions
seemingly concluded the matrix trilogy
reeves and costa carrigan mars would be
reuniting with director lana wachowski
to shoot a fourth matrix film
the film will be held only by lana
without her sister lily with whom she
co-directed the first three matrix films
rumors of a new matrix movie has been
swirling around for a few years but most
signs seem to point to a reboot of the
popular franchise centering a new
character
not a sequel with the original cast
however now it's clear that wachowski's
script will once again follow reeves and
master's character neo and trinity it
makes sense that reeves would want to
keep his schedule wide open
with production now slated to ramp up in
2020 the new matrix film will keep
reeves occupied
well into phase 4 of the mcu which may
explain why he hasn't been eager to jump
on board the marvel train just yet
but it's not just his long slate of
upcoming projects that could be keeping
reeves too busy to enter the mcu reeves
is a man of many interests and talents
and he's dabbled in a variety of
professions throughout the years
in 2011 when the mcu was first gathering
steam keanu was starting the arch
motorcycle company
reeves has been a die-hard motorcycle
enthusiast for over three decades
with an extensive personal collection of
much-loved bikes that he's carefully
curated over the years
arch allows him to feed his passion for
motorcycles creating custom high-end
bikes that can carry price tags of over
120 000
and which reeves is clearly tremendously
proud of outside of acting and
motorcycles reeves has also played base
in the band duck star
written and published books with artist
alexandra grant and produced a number of
films
now it's not unheard of the mcu actors
to carve out time to pursue other
endeavors
just look at jeremy renner's singing
career and mark ruffalo's tireless work
against climate change but it can't be
easy to balance outside interest with
the strenuous demands of an mcu contract
with so many irons in the fire
reeves may enjoy the freedom of not
being logged into a multi-year marvel
contract
even if he's still able to squeeze
everything in around any potential
superhero gig the stress of juggling
them all may make it difficult to
actually enjoy
any of them and if you're not enjoying
your passion projects what's the point
of doing them at all
beyond the demands of their long
contracts mcu actors also live under
constant and relentless public scrutiny
in addition to starring in the movies
themselves they're expected to engage in
extensive promotion for marvel's films
answering the same questions over and
over for a never-ending parade of
journalists and talk show hosts and
while reeves is an a-list star already
the notoriously private and introverted
actor may be daunted by the idea of
throwing himself into the mcu limelight
speaking about reeves to gq john wick
chapter 2 actor peter stormer has said
he's a loner they think he's putting on
some kind of a fake face when he's
stuttering giving interviews on the red
carpet and he looks away and looks
uncomfortable
but he really is considering just how
many red carpets marvel actors have to
walk
it's possible that reeves has decided
that being part of the mcu
just isn't worth being forced to spend
so much time in the public eye
due to marvel's reliance on returning
cast members and their movies demanding
production schedule
the studio has never been particularly
eager to take risks when it comes to its
stars
not only could injury-induced production
delays throw their entire multi-year
plan off track but the cost of ensuring
its a-list stars while they perform
their own stunts will be astronomical
because of this marvel actors are
contractually prohibited from doing the
bulk of their own stunt work but reeves
is known for doing most of his own
stunts
and may indeed be turned off by marvel's
hardline policy
speaking about john wick chapter 3
director and former reeve stunned double
chad stahlski
told gq if you've got an actor who can
ride horses ride motorcycles do fight
scenes
why not i made a list of every skill
kiano has
we sat down and i said give me
everything you can do really well
and we put all that in the movies now
that he's accustomed to action movies
that play to his physical strengths
and allow him to showcase his
considerable action skills it wouldn't
be surprising if being hamstrung by a
studio contract seems less than
appealing to reeves then there's a
chance that marvel has been offering him
roles that aren't exactly super physical
for example reeves may have made a great
collector everett k
ross or even steven strange but none of
those roles would have tapped into the
sort of physicality the actor is known
for
after all it would be a bit of a let
down for both the audience and for
reeves himself
if the actor known for doing 90 of his
action scenes and stunned heavy movies
finally took a role in the mcu and ended
up just standing there and waving his
hands for most of the time
being the huge fan of comic books that
he is there's a good chance that the
reason reeves has been reluctant to take
a role in the mcu
is because he's holding out for the
chance to play one specific character
in fact there are a number of roles
within the marvel universe that reeves
would be well suited to play
adam warlock the perfect being teased at
the end of guardians of the galaxy vol 2
could be a good fit for reeves who let's
face it is often rumored to be perfect
himself
another option might be reed richards
the leader of the fantastic four
disney recently reclaimed the fantastic
four from fox and with tony stark gone
after the events of avengers end game
the mcu has a space open for a new
scientist hero
along with the fantastic four comes
alien antagonist turned ally silver
surfer
who could also provide a meaty role for
reefs or maybe reeves wants to play
ghost rider
a character that he's always been a fan
of and one that would allow him to bring
his love of motorcycles to the mcu
while this character was already
introduced in the tv series marvel's
agents of shield
it wouldn't be a huge surprise if the
character was recast for the big screen
especially if marvel could pull in an
actor of reeves caliber to play him
keanu reeves has also told mtv in the
past that one of his favorite comic book
stories is frank miller's friend of
wolverine
due to marvel's sale of the rights to
the x-men to fox in the 90s mutants have
never appeared in the mcu so far
that may be about to change with
disney's recent acquisition of [ __ ] at
san diego comic-con in 2019
kevin feige recently hinted that mutants
were indeed on the horizon
for the mcu which may be exactly what
reeves has been waiting for
reeves told mtv i always wanted to play
wolverine i missed that one with mutants
now finally headed to the mcu reeves may
finally get his chance to sport a set of
adamantium claws
at the end of the day however the mcu
may just have nothing to offer keanu
reeves a man who is already one of the
most beloved actors in hollywood who
cares very little about money and who is
by all accounts
a genuinely good person who frequently
goes out of his way to make the world a
better place for others
the feeling of of being there of
walking the streets of the future is
really going to be breathtaking
acting in the mcu can give a huge boost
to an actor's career catapulting them
from relative unknowns to some of the
most sought-after names in hollywood
practically overnight but for an actor
like reeves who is already a household
name with enough star power to pursue
pretty much any project he wants to make
that may not be much of an incentive to
sign up for a decade-long contract with
marvel
similarly reeves doesn't exactly need
the mcu to endear him to the many fans
who already love him
marvel actors are expected to be heroes
both off and on the big screen
but reeves doesn't exactly need a studio
contract to prompt him to be generous
and kind
and he's consistently reported to be
among the nicest people
anyone could ever have the pleasure of
meeting you're breathtaking
you're all breathtaking and that's the
crux of it
why you play a superhero when you're
already one in real life
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one